là on est vraiment dans
le le flou le plus complet quoi
qu'est-il arrivé à Robert Pichon
personne peut répondre
en effet rien ne prouve jusqu'à présent
que Robert Pichon ait été tué et brûlé
dans la maison de Sainte-Hélène
13 novembre 2007 nous sommes au cœur du
massif des Vosges à Senones une petite
ville de 3000 habitants
ce mardi là c'est un jour comme les
autres à la brigade de gendarmerie du
village il est 14h
lorsqu'un jeune couple se présente
ce couple c'est Maud Tellier qui a 26
ans et son compagnon Olivier Benoît qui
en a 34
[Musique]
le visage d'Olivier Benoît n'est pas
totalement étranger aux officiers et
pour cause c'est un délinquant notoire
dans la région
la classe est judiciaire de braqueurs il
est connu aussi pour être un toxicoman
dans le dans le secteur de Moyenmoutier
où il habite quoi donc il est on va dire
fiché par la justice et à peine arrivé à
la gendarmerie motellier et Olivier
Benoit font un aveu incroyable
quand le couple arrive dans cette
gendarmerie ils sont au comptoir face
aux plantons et il va se passer un truc
absolument extraordinaire c'est qu'ils
vont dire quasiment de concert voilà on
vient vous voir parce qu'on a tué notre
voisin
on est dans un petit village dans un
département où il ne se passe pas grand
chose et c'est un peu la stupéfaction si
vous voulez les gendarmes regarde c'est
de là en faisant qu'est-ce qui viennent
nous raconter
les gendarmes ne comprennent pas très
très bien ce qui est en train d'arriver
c'est pas des choses qui arrivent
régulièrement ce genre de situation les
gendarmes tombent des nues c'est bien la
première fois que quelqu'un vient ainsi
revendiquer un crime
habituellement les gendarmes cherchent
les auteurs d'un corps qu'ils ont
retrouvé assassinés là on vient leur
expliquer que quelqu'un était assassiné
et ils ont pas eu à arrêter ces gens-là
ils viennent spontanément se livrer les
deux jeunes gens racontent que leur
victime serait incertain Robert Pichon
un retraité de 61 ans ami et voisins du
couple à Moyenmoutier à une trentaine de
kilomètres de là
Olivier Benoit motelier et Robert Pichon
se connaissent depuis le début de
l'année 2007 janvier allez on va dire
décembre 2006 janvier 2016 ils sont pour
ainsi dire voisin alors l'appartement du
couple Benoît Tellier et puis la maison
de Robert Pichon et sur une espèce de
petite plage la place d'obertal à
Moyenmoutier donc si vous voulez on peut
les considérer comme des voisins au fil
du temps ils ont appris à se connaître à
s'apprécier et puis à se faire confiance
donc c'était initialement des relations
de voisinage qui ont au fil du temps
dérivés en des relations d'amitié je
crois qu'on peut on peut le dire
aussi tous les gendarmes s'interrogent
pourquoi le couple aurait-il tué leur
ami qui est ce Robert Pichon et pourquoi
le couple vient-il se dénoncer c'est une
histoire pour le moins étonnante que
Maud délier Olivier Benoît vont raconter
aux gendarmes
[Musique]
les deux jeunes gens sont immédiatement
auditionnés individuellement
mode délier et Olivier Benoît vont
raconter dans le moindre détail le
déroulement du crime de témoignages en
tout point
identiques
l'histoire commence six semaines plus
tôt le 26 septembre 2007 dans la matinée
le couple se serait rendu à
Sainte-Hélène un petit village où la mer
d'Olivier Benoît possède une maison
il serait venu chercher du bois et
aurait demandé à leurs voisins Robert
Pichon de les accompagner pour les aider
Olivier Benoît motelier et Robert Pichon
décide d'aller couper du bois ou Olivier
Benoît ou en tout cas la mère de Olivier
Benoist a une sorte de maison et il
emmène Robert Pichon pour tout
simplement faire du bois de chauffage
mais Olivier Benoit et Maud délier
affirme qu'à peine arrivé sur place ils
ont commencé à se sentir très nerveux et
pour cause ces deux toxicomanes en
sevrage aurait commencé à ressentir
violemment les effets du manque
les deux sont toxico héroïnomènes depuis
des années et ils ont décidé d'arrêter
mais ne pourra arrêter ils utilisent le
Subutex donc un produit de substitution
à l'héroïne pour calmer les crises de
manque
une pensée avoir un stock de produits de
substitution sur place et s'aperçoit en
arrivant que en réalité le stock est
vide
Olivier repart seul à Moyenmoutier pour
rechercher des produits pour passer la
journée à Sainte-Hélène
[Applaudissements]
Olivier parti mode délier et Robert
Pichon sont alors seuls dans cette
maison isolée en pleine campagne
nous sommes en plein hiver il fait froid
et maux Tellier raconte au gendarmes
qu'elle aurait proposé à Robert Pichon
de faire du feu dans la maison
[Musique]
ce que dit mode c'est que elle est en
train de de d'attiser le feu auprès d'un
fournil donc elle est penchée en avant
Robert Pichon l'aurait alors suivi près
de la cheminée
et contre toute attente le vieil homme
lui aurait fait des avances
mot Tellier affirme ensuite que Robert
Pichon l'aurait attrapé par la robe et
aurait commis un geste déplacé
il m'a mis un doigt ça prendra pas
longtemps me répéter-il ta qu'à te
laisser faire
Robert Pichon ça donnerait des
attouchements il aurait craqué il aurait
été pris apparemment de pulsion en tout
cas ce que raconte mode Tellier Robert
Pichon aurait agressé c'est ce que dit
homothélier aurait agressé sexuellement
la jeune femme pour se défendre mot
Tellier ce serait alors saisi d'un outil
posé à côté de la cheminée
[Musique]
et elle va le frapper à plusieurs
reprises jusqu'à ce qu'il tombe
à plusieurs reprises Maud frappe
violemment Robert Pichon avec un manche
de hache
la jeune femme explique que le manque de
drogue a décuplé son agressivité
au moment où elle se fait agresser
les choses
que elle a eu comme un coup de sang bon
sachant qu'en plus peut-être elle était
en manque puisqu'il n'avait pas pu
prendre en quantité suffisante de leurs
produits de substitution donc elle dit
avoir eu une réaction extrêmement
violente
modélier explique que ce n'est qu'après
quelques secondes qu'elle se serait
rendu compte de la gravité de son geste
lorsqu'elle voit cet homme là s'écrouler
sur le le pas de la porte
elle l'explique elle dit je
n'ai pas osé je n'ai pas osé aller même
ne serait-ce que toucher et voir s'il
était vivant ou pas j'ai vu du sang
s'écouler de la bouche elle sait
effondrée bon elle s'est effondrée dans
un coin de la pièce et elle a attendu
qu'Olivier Benoit revienne
ce n'est qu'une heure plus tard en fin
de matinée qu'Olivier Benoît serait
revenu à Sainte-Hélène et qu'il aurait
constaté le drame
il constate l'ampleur des dégâts c'est à
dire qu'il poussent la porte il a le
corps de Robert Pichon qui est là même
le sol
Olivier Benoit voit un corps qui est
assis dont s'est écoulé du sang au
niveau de au niveau de la bouche il y a
des traces de sang sur le sol à côté de
Robert Pichon dans une partie un petit
peu incurvée du sol
Maud lui raconte ce qu'il s'est passé
Olivier Benoît s'assure de l'état de
santé de Robert Pichon et on arrive à la
conclusion de ce dernier est décédé
face aux gendarmes Olivier Benoit
explique que son premier réflexe a été
de vouloir appeler les secours pour tout
leur raconter mais qu'au dernier moment
il aurait paniqué il a peur parce qu'il
est connu des services de police parce
qu'il a peur qu'on ne le croit pas
compte tenu de son passé judiciaire
c'est l'intoxicomane qui a fait 12 ans
de prison 12 ans de réclusion criminelle
pour des volamars
il est connu donc pour des affaires de
toxicomanie ce qui ne va pas arranger
c'est ses affaires ses relations avec
les services de police ou de gendarmerie
hanté par le fait qu'on ne va pas le
croire il me dit quoi que je fasse quoi
que je dise on dira c'est pas vrai moi
j'ai un passé j'ai un passif judiciaire
un passif d'incarcération
on ne me croira pas
Olivier Benoit et persuadé qu'il fera
d'autant plus figure de suspect idéal
que sa compagne Maude ne porte aucun
stigmate de l'agression qu'elle a subi
voit bien que Maude n'a pas de séquelles
de traces de de violence sur elle ses
vêtements ne sont pas déchirés
elle a pas reçu de coup elle a pas un
bleu elle a pas elle est pas griffé
faute de preuves pour étayer la
tentative de viol et la légitime défense
les deux jeunes gens expliquent aux
enquêteurs qu'ils n'ont trouvé qu'une
seule solution pour s'en sortir
alors alors on va se débarrasser du
corps alors ce meurtre n'aura pas eu
lieu mais alors comment faire
motelier Olivier Benoît affirme avoir
tout improvisé
[Musique]
qui vont enrouler le corps dans un dans
un drap
le chargé dans une brouette ils vont à
l'arrière de la maison dans le champ et
là il tombe sur un tas de bois c'est
simple on va on va le brûler
Olivier Benoit et Maud Tellier aurait
chargé les rondins de bois puis aurait
méthodiquement constitué le bûcher
[Musique]
ils font un sandwich ce qu'ils appellent
eux en tout cas c'est ce qui raconte aux
enquêteurs un sandwich avec le corps de
Robert Pichon c'est à dire que une
couche de bois le corps une seconde
couche de bois
Olivier benoit va prendre de l'essence
qui se trouvait dans un réservoir de
moto ou de voitures dans le jardin
arroser le bûcher et d'essence pour que
ça prenne naturellement et ça brûle plus
facilement
enfin Olivier Benoît aurait allumé le
foyer à l'aide d'un briquet
[Musique]
seulement voilà l'embrasement aurait été
si soudain qu'Olivier aurait été touché
par les flammes
[Musique]
il a quand même ce réflexe de se jeter
au sol et de se rouler dans l'herbe pour
éteindre l'incendie il est quand même
brûlé sur toute une partie du corps le
bras un peu le visage il se débrouleur
qu'ils font extrêmement mal il n'arrive
pas à le supporter mode délier va tenter
de le soigner avec des crèmes
hydratantes de la biogaz enfin des
choses comme ça mais les blessures sont
beaucoup trop graves beaucoup trop
importantes on peut pas le laisser comme
ça
alors que le corps de Robert Pichon
serait encore en train de se consumer à
ciel ouvert
le couple affirme s'être rendu aux
urgences de l'hôpital le plus proche
les douleurs doivent être assez
insupportables donc ils décident d'aller
se faire soigner à Saint-Dié
aux urgences de l'hôpital Saint-Jacques
de Saint-Dizier le diagnostic des
médecins est formel les brûlures
d'Olivier Benon à son trop importante
pour qu'il reste dans l'établissement
l'homme doit rejoindre au plus vite un
centre spécialisé pour les grands brûlés
devant l'ampleur des brûlures ce qui
laisse à penser qu'effectivement c'était
lors d'une lors d'une opération et de la
mise en place d'un feu important les
médecins décident de l'héliporter à Metz
ce qui signifie manifestement que les
brûlures sont très importantes
Olivier Benoît et transporté au centre
hospitalier régional de Metz à 150 km de
là mais comme il l'explique aux
gendarmes malgré la douleur il n'aurait
eu qu'une idée en tête faire disparaître
le corps de Robert Pichon à tel point
qu'il aurait pris une décision radicale
qui est complètement brûlé qui devrait
rester plusieurs jours finalement c'est
quand même qu'un corps qui brûle dans le
sens jardin donc il signe une décharge
de responsabilité pour pouvoir sortir de
cet hôpital plutôt seulement le jeune
homme va très vite se rendre compte que
les choses ne se sont pas du tout passé
comme il les avait prévues
[Applaudissements]
c'est dans la nuit qu'Olivier Benoît
émotélier serait rentré à Sainte-Hélène
mais arrivé sur place ils auraient
découvert que le corps de Robert Pichon
ne s'était pas entièrement conçu mais
lorsqu'ils arrivent sur place ils
s'aperçoivent que c'est une catastrophe
parce que le corps n'a pas complètement
disparu n'a pas complètement brûlé
malgré je crois qu'il y avait trois
quatre cinq stères de bois pour
alimenter le foyer et on sait que un
corps c'est très difficile à faire
disparaître les zones ne disparaissent
pas comme ça et il faut des stères et
des stères de bois pour pour que ça se
disparaisse totalement
insistez de mode Olivier Benoît aurait
alors décidé de raviver les flammes
ils expliquent qu'ils ont rallumé le feu
ils ont ils ont voilà ils ont brûlé le
tout jusqu'à ce qu'il ne reste plus rien
laissons le bûcher finir de se consumer
le couple serait rentré dans la maison
pour nettoyer méticuleusement la scène
de crime
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mode explique qu'elle a nettoyé avec des
produits détergents classiques
déterminés les deux amants n'auraient
épargnés aucun détail ils auraient même
employé les grands moyens Olivier Benoit
aplâté cette partie qui était un petit
peu incurvée pour justement masquer ce
qui pouvait rester de ces traces de de
son
[Musique]
ils vont déplacer des meubles ils vont
repeindre des meubles même pour essayer
de faire en sorte même pas de peut-être
de traces d'empreinte rien voilà tout va
être lessivé tout va être nettoyé
repeint plâtré donc il y a plus rien
le couple précise qu'il aurait jeté les
dernières preuves au feu d'abord un
rideau qui aurait servi à éponger les
traces de sang ainsi que le manche d'une
hache avec lequel motellier ce serait
défendu contre son agresseur
et Olivier ne se serait pas arrêté là
pour faire disparaître les traces du
bûcher faire disparaître éventuellement
les traces de corps enfin de de peau
dedans qui auraient pu rester sur place
il explique Olivier Benoît avoir gratté
le sol avoir ramassé l'ensemble de ce
qu'il avait récolté du l'emplacement du
bûcher avoir rempli des sauts et être
allé les vider à Épinal
c'est à une vingtaine de kilomètres de
Sainte-Hélène au port d'Épinal que maux
Tellier Olivier Benoit dit s'être
débarrassé des cendres du cadavre de
Robert Pichon
ensemble ils auraient jeté les deux
seaux dans le canal supprimant par la
même les ultimes preuves potentiels
le récit du couple particulièrement
méticuleux et détaillé ressemble à si
mes prendre un scénario élaboré par des
criminels chevronnés et ils ont pensé à
tout afin d'éviter que les voisins ne se
posent trop de questions sur la
disparition de Robert Pichon ils
auraient alors brouillé les pistes en
lui invantant une nouvelle vie ils
avouent qu'ils ont essayé de faire
croire à l'entourage de Robert sur
l'entourage de Robert Pichon c'est assez
réduit parce que c'est pas quelqu'un qui
avait une vie mondaine ou sociale
intense Robert Pichon quoi donc auprès
de ces gens-là ils font croire qu'il est
parti en vacances dans le Sud où il est
censé avoir de l'habitation à Cannes le
couple aurait alors tout mis en oeuvre
pour accréditer leurs propos et
convaincre tout le monde que Robert
Pichon et bel et bien parti sur la Côte
d'Azur
comment le font-ils ils le font en
procédant à des retraits d'argent avec
sa carte bancaire alors étant précisé
qu'ils avaient le code en secret de
Robert Pichon parce qu'ils avaient des
liens d'amitié assez assez profond et
puis Robert Pichon leur avait donné le
code de la carte bleue pour faire
diverses courbes etc donc Olivier Benoît
fait des retraits d'argent sur les
Vosges dans le sud à Cannes et puis
également à Paris ils le font vivre
également en payant des factures
courantes de Robert Pichon EDF tout ce
que tout ce que tout le monde peut payer
et on voit également des SMS avec le
téléphone de Robert Pichon donc dans
différents lieux pour la géolocalisation
que ce soit à Cannes ou à Paris sur le
téléphone d'Olivier Benoit en lui disant
c'est Robert tout va bien etc etc donc
ils le font vivre pendant un certain
laps de temps
le plan élaboré par Maud et Olivier a
été si bien pensé que personne jusqu'à
aujourd'hui ne se souciait du sort de
Robert Pichon allez croire ce serait
donc un crime parfait que le couple
vient d'avouer au gendarmes le corps
disparaît personne ne recherche la
victime
donc s'il ne se rendent pas
personne ne va venir leur poser des
questions les interroger ou si on les
interroge ils diront ce qu'ils avaient
commencé à dire que même monsieur Pichon
il est parti en vacances nous on n'en
sait pas plus il nous a dit qu'il
partait là
les enquêteurs s'interrogent pourquoi
donc un mois et demi après la mort
supposée de Robert Pichon après avoir
brouillé les pistes et alors que
personne jusqu'à présent ne
s'interrogeait sur la disparition du
retraité pourquoi ce couple est-il venu
se dénoncer Olivier Benoît se rend
compte que sa compagne bien affectée
parce qu'il s'appelle ce qui s'est passé
je serai on le sera à moi il
dans un premier temps il décide de
prendre la fuite
donc ils prennent leur véhicule et puis
descendre direction l'Espagne et puis
discute évidemment sur le chemin et puis
arrivé du côté de Lyon Valence
il décide que ça suffit ils font
demi-tour et vont à la gendarmerie pour
se livrer
Olivier Benoît et Maude Tellier
vont expliquer que s'ils se sont
constitués prisonniers s'ils sont venus
raconter cette histoire au gendarmes
c'est qu'ils étaient pris de remords et
qu'il voulait soulager leur conscience
ce retour à la gendarmerie marque donc
la fin du récit
une fois leur déposition signée
motellier Olivier Benoît sont placés en
garde à vue
la priorité des gendarmes et désormais
de vérifier point par point les
dépositions du couple
mais les enquêteurs vont très vite s'en
rendre compte cette histoire suscite bon
nombre de questions
ce soir-là de novembre 2016 commence à
faire Pichon
le lendemain le 14 novembre 2007 les
gendarmes entame leur toute première
investigations mais pour eux la tâche
s'annonce ardue car cette affaire est
plus inhabituelle
la première particularité je crois que
c'est une affaire dans laquelle les
enquêteurs vont travailler à l'envers
puisque vous avez deux personnes qui
vont se dénoncer dans une gendarmerie
disant nous avons tué quelqu'un et nous
avons fait disparaître le corps pour les
gendarmes il est donc urgent de trouver
des indices pour permettre de confirmer
la version du couple
[Musique]
les experts scientifiques de la
gendarmerie se rendent alors sur les
lieux du crime suppose
[Musique]
la police scientifique de la gendarmerie
commence à débarquer dans la maison de
Sainte-Hélène quoi et comment ça a passé
au cri pour essayer de trouver des
traces qui corroborent une corroborerait
pas quoi la version la version des des
deux des deux suspects quoi des deux
personnes qui viennent se livrer
théoriquement aussi il y a eu un meurtre
les experts devraient retrouver des
traces sans trop de problèmes
c'est quand même pas des grands
professionnels de la difficulté de crime
effectivement Montélier et Olivier
Benoist surtout qu'en plus si ce qui
décrivait ils n'ont pas prévu donc ils
se retrouvent confrontés à quelque chose
qui les dépasse qu'il est qu'ils ont pas
ils ont choisi ni l'endroit ni le moment
quoi donc normalement ça va laisser des
on doit retrouver des traces
les experts s'intéressent tout
particulièrement à la porte d'entrée là
où maux Tellier dit avoir porté le coup
fatal
là où Olivier Benoit aurait retrouvé
Robert Pichon gisant dans son sang
ce qui nous raconte c'est que quand
votre Tellier frappe Robert Pichon il y
a effectivement beaucoup de sang
projetés c'est absolument évident du
sang au sol mais du sens sur les murs on
peut imaginer la violence de la scène et
donc il y a du sang projeter des gouttes
parfois des micro-gouttes etc etc et
pour révéler des traces de sang les
experts scientifiques ont une méthode
infaillible même quand la scène de crime
a été entièrement nettoyée
retrouver des traces notamment avec un
produit qui s'appelle le Blue Star qui a
un produit qui permet de révéler des
traces de sang qui sont invisibles à
l'œil nu
si du sang a été lavé en quelques
secondes des taches bleues fluorescentes
apparaissent au contact du produit
après quelques instants il faut se
rendre à l'évidence le produit ne réagit
pas
[Musique]
il ne retrouvera rien
bizarrement il y a plus une seule trace
de même pas une micro goutte de sang qui
reste dans cette maison aucune trace de
son nid sur le mur
ni sur le sol
les enquêteurs vont alors s'intéresser
au pas de la porte d'entrée là où le son
de Robert Pichon aurait coulé
Olivier Benoît avait déclaré qu'il avait
replâtré l'entrée de la maison parce
qu'il y avait du son
on a ôté les le plâtre on a des scellé
et on a effectivement retrouvé deux
tâches de sang humain mais s'agit-il du
sang de Robert Pichon
impossible de l'affirmer
on sait que c'est du sang humain mais on
sait pas qu'il appartient
comme le 101 enfin en tout cas le sol
avait été lavé avec des produits
détergents etc ils ne peuvent absolument
pas l'attribuer à tel ou telle personne
factuellement ça prouve rien la
conclusion des enquêteurs c'est que dans
la maison il ne retire aucun élément
matériel permettant d'aller dans le sens
de la version donnée par Olivier Benoit
et motellier soit éventuellement dans le
sens d'une autre version
quelques gouttes de sang à peine pas
d'ADN identifiable pas non plus
d'empreintes digitales rien ne prouve
jusqu'à présent qu'un crime était commis
dans cette pièce
[Musique]
alors les experts mis sur le jardin
l'endroit où le couple dit avoir brûlé
le corps
reste une dernière expertise
scientifique à effectuer pour savoir si
Robert Pichon a bien été carbonisé à cet
endroit précis
car dès qu'un cadavre est exposé à l'air
libre il attire des insectes qui se
nourrissent de cher morte des larves qui
apparaissent généralement dans les trois
heures suivant le décès on appelle cela
des insectes nécrophages
pour revenir sur les faits on sait qu'il
y a eu deux créations une première où il
s'est brûlé
où il a dû partir à l'hôpital en
laissant le corps comme ça en l'état qui
n'était évidemment pas complètement
consumé donc il y avait des restes
humains selon la version du couple des
restes humains qui auraient
nécessairement parce que ça durait
longtemps
attirer ses insectes nécrophages et donc
si ça avait été le cas on en aurait
retrouvé des traces or là en
l'occurrence on ne retrouve aucune trace
du passage de ces insectes nécrophages
donc là ça pose un problème
seulement un mois et demi s'est écoulé
et les traces d'insectes ont très bien
pu disparaître
mais il y a une autre possibilité
Robert Plichon n'avait peut-être pas été
carbonisé ici
on sait faire disparaître un corps en le
prenant c'est très compliqué parce qu'un
corps est composé essentiellement d'eau
quoi et qui a des parties en plus comme
étant les autres qui sont censés ne pas
brûler ou alors des températures telles
qui il faut des fours industriels
aujourd'hui la science permet de
retrouver un corps c'est quasiment
impossible de dissimuler totalement
encore on sait très bien qu'un corps ne
brûle pas intégralement et puis ADN et
puis etc etc etc on ne retrouve rien on
y retrouve rien
aucune trace du corps aucune trace de
feu c'est à ni rien comprendre
alors les gendarmes vont employer les
grands moyens la gendarmerie va même
faire appel à
nos satellites français qui sont en
orbite autour de la planète pour savoir
si par hasard au moment des faits un
satellite militaire aurait pu ou non
draguer le coin où il y avait la commune
de Sainte-Hélène pour voir si
effectivement il y aurait eu une trace
de fumée etc puis malheureusement le
satellite est passé je crois trois jours
avant ou trois jours après mais en tout
cas pas le bonjour ou en tout cas pas au
bon moment pour tenter d'avoir le fin
mot de cette histoire les enquêteurs
vont alors vérifier un détail dans la
déposition du couple
[Musique]
port d'Épinal le 22 novembre 2016
les gendarmes se rendent à l'endroit
précis où le couple raconte avoir jeté
les cendres de Robert Pichon car il
cherche un indice très précis des restes
du corps qui sont impossibles à détruire
par le feu
il y a pas beaucoup de courant à cet
endroit là donc des plongeurs de la
gendarmerie sans doute aidés par les
pompiers dans sa spécialité vont
organiser sur un périmètre de 4 500
mètres organisé des plongées pour
essayer de retrouver des morceaux
d'ossements parce que les cendres
évidemment on va pas les retrouver
ça a eu lieu les plongeurs ont fait leur
travail
ils n'ont rien trouvé ça vient donner un
autre regard sur eux sur le couple quoi
parce qu'on se dit où c'est des gens qui
ont eu beaucoup de chance
qui ont comme il y a écrit on n'arrive
jamais à rien à rien prouver quoi ou
alors c'est quasiment des génies du
crime quoi
là on est vraiment dans
le flou le plus complet quoi qu'est-il
arrivé à Robert Pichon personne peut
répondre
en effet rien ne prouve jusqu'à présent
que Robert Pichon ait été tué et brûlé
dans la maison de Sainte-Hélène
les enquêteurs en viennent à
s'interroger l'homme serait-il toujours
vivant et dans ce cas où serait-il passé
les gendarmes vont tenter partout les
moyens de trouver la trace du retraitée
en vain
[Musique]
bon passer en revue au crible ses
comptes ces relations médicales des
liens qu'il a avec les avec les médecins
son portable et on voit que rien ne
bouge quoi bref tout concours à laisser
penser c'est mort
et puis depuis le 26 date à laquelle eux
disent avoir tué quoi effectivement
personne ne l'a vu il a pu donner aucun
signe de vie
enfin il y a un dernier détail à
vérifier les brûlures supposées
d'Olivier Benoît sur son bras gauche et
sur son visage alors qu'il aurait mis le
feu au cadavre de Robert Pichon
or le registre de l'hôpital
Saint-Jacques à Saint-Dié-des-Vosges et
formel il prouve que le 26 septembre
2007 jour de la mort supposée du
retraitée le jeune homme a bien été
admis aux urgences puis transféré au
centre hospitalier de Metz
à ce stade les gendarmes disposent de
quelques éléments Davos circonstancié
mais d'aucune preuve formelle alors il
décide de perquisitionner le domicile du
couple et sur place ils vont enfin
obtenir un indice une saisie est opérée
d'un bas de pantalon de jogging
d'Olivier Benoist sur lequel on retrouve
une trace de sang le pantalon est
formellement identifié par Maud comme
étant celui que portait Olivier Benoît
le jour du crime supposé
reste à savoir si le sang est bien celui
de Robert Pichon
[Musique]
l'expert indique très précisément que le
sang qui est retrouvé sur le pantalon de
d'Olivier Benoit et bel et bien celui de
Robert Pichon
alors au début les enquêteurs sont à
vrai dire assez contents d'avoir
finalement
pour la première fois quelque chose qui
lui est relié à Robert pigeon Robert
pigeon on regarde jamais vu un moment on
ne sait plus très bien et on dit bah si
en fait c'est voilà on a du sang une
simple tâche de sang pour corroborer les
aveux du couple c'est bien mince
mais les enquêteurs ne vont pas tarder à
découvrir que la relation entre Maud
délier Olivier Benoît et Robert Pichon
ne serait pas seulement amical
dans les jours qui suivent les
enquêteurs vont découvrir qu'en août
2007 un mois seulement avant le drame
Robert Pichon avait porté plainte il
affirmait alors avoir été victime d'un
cambriolage
Robert Pichon était hospitalisé pendant
le mois d'août 2007 et pendant son
hospitalisation sa maison a été
cambriolée et dégradé les meubles tout a
disparu l'électroménager là ici etc
donc quand il revient de son
hospitalisation on constate les dégâts
et puis le vol et va déposer une plainte
compte tenu de l'importance du préjudice
les gendarmes avaient pris la Féro
sérieux et donc ils avaient enquêté
en effectuant plusieurs perquisitions et
une enquête de voisinage les gendarmes
apprennent quelque chose de
particulièrement surprenant là il
s'aperçoit
que le cambriolage a été orchestré avec
la complicité de Robert Pichon
pendant qu'il était hospitalisé et que
le principal auteur de ce cambriolage
n'était autre qu'Olivier Benoît pour les
gendarmes le cambriolage pourrait en
fait dissimuler une escroquerie à
l'assurance qui aurait été organisée par
Robert Pichon et le couple Tellier
Benoît
face aux enquêteurs le couple à vous
[Musique]
de concert ils se mettent d'accord
puisque ils ont tous besoin d'argent
c'est vivre de manière assez modeste
mode Tellier et coiffeuse au chômage
Olivier Benoît lui il travaille fait des
petits boulots d'intérim et l'autre est
retraité et donc voilà c'est trois là
n'ont pas beaucoup d'argent donc il
s'imaginent simuler un cambriolage dans
la maison de Robert Pichon pendant son
absence la vidé du mobilier et dans le
même temps commettre un certain nombre
de dégradations pour obtenir une
indemnisation de la compagnie
d'assurance sachant que Robert Pichon a
priori était plutôt bien assuré
une fois que Robert Pichon aurait été
remboursé de
son préjudice soit une somme de 50000
euros et bien il l'aurait partagé
tout ça a été dit à l'avance et l'idée
étant de toucher à la fois l'argent de
l'assurance et de revendre les meubles
c'est informations interpelle
particulièrement les enquêteurs il se
demande si en fait la mort présumée de
Robert Pichon ne dissimulerait pas un
règlement de compte
à ce moment-là peut-être que Olivier
Benoit s'est dit mais pourquoi pourquoi
partager alors que je peux tout prendre
et en faisant disparaître Robert Pichon
il règle tous les problèmes et il
encaisse 50 000 euros
des enquêteurs et d'accusation c'est
vous avez supprimé Robert Pichon pour
toucher cet argent qui qui s'apprêtait à
venir et la défense répond assez
habilement mais attendez c'était pas mon
argent moi je suis Olivier Benoit je
expliquez-moi comment j'aurais pu
toucher cet argent et tant qu'à faire
autant attendre que l'argent soit versé
parce que par définition puisqu'il est
mort l'argent ne sera pas versé a priori
la thèse de l'escroquerie à l'assurance
tombe à l'eau mais les enquêteurs vont
découvrir d'autres éléments qui
pourraient tout de même corroborer la
thèse de l'escroquerie
janvier 2009 après un peu plus d'un an
d'enquête les gendarmes perquisitionnent
le cabinet d'assurance qui assure les
biens de Robert Pichon
dans le dossier du retraité ils vont
découvrir des procurations dans
lesquelles le vieil homme aurait donné
plein pouvoir à Olivier Benoist sur ses
finances en cas d'invalidité ou de décès
l'information est de taille
la découverte de ses procurations
prouve tout simplement
qu'Olivier Benoît
allait pouvait encaisser le montant du
remboursement de l'assurance et pas que
ça du reste puisqu'il avait une
procuration également sur les comptes
bancaires et donc qu'en gros il avait pu
besoin de de Robert Pichon et que si
Robert Pichon venait à disparaître il se
trouvait à la tête de la fortune entre
guillemets de Robert Pichon
les enquêteurs ont le sentiment qu'ils
tiennent là la clé de l'affaire qui
tiendra un mobile seulement une question
se pose quelle aurait été l'intérêt pour
Robert Pichon de signer ses fameuses
procurations
le juge en charge de l'affaire se
demande si ses papiers ne sont pas en
réalité des faux
il doit impérativement s'assurer pour
asseoir son sa thèse du motif crapuleux
de savoir qui a fait quoi sur ces sur
ses écrits pour retentifier l'origine de
ses procurations et savoir si Olivier
Benoît aurait pu préméditer le meurtre
supposé le juge ordonne pas moins de 4
expertises graphologiques problèmes les
résultats vont s'avérer plutôt
contradictoire le juge d'instruction
nomme plusieurs experts et au final les
experts en tout cas un nombre d'experts
plus important dit que c'est Robert
Pichon qui a bel et bien signé ses
procurations et un expert dit que c'est
Olivier Benoit qui a signé ses
procurations
ces fameuses procurations ont été
analysées là en l'occurrence il y en a
une qui dit que c'est lui qui dit que
c'est pas lui pour l'heure les gendarmes
n'ont aucune preuve permettant d'établir
l'après méditation
toutefois un nouvel élément va mettre à
mal la version de la légitime défense
servie par Maud délier un élément qui
laisse penser qu'elle a menti sur le
scénario de ce qui se serait passé le
jour du crime
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en effet les enquêteurs découvrent un
certificat médical un document dans
lequel le médecin affirme que son
patient est impuissant
cette attestation
d'impuissance cette attestation médicale
d'un puissance de Robert Pichon
l'accusation va s'en emparer comme d'un
élément à charge contre mode délier en
disant mais comment voulez-vous cet
homme qui est impuissant et tenté de
vous violer madame
cet argument est balayé d'un revers de
main par les avocats de la défense pour
ce certificat ne prouverait rien bien au
contraire il aurait été établi dans des
circonstances pour le moins troublant
ce certificat pose quand même un sérieux
problème puisque le médecin a été
entendu dans le cadre de l'enquête pour
savoir dans quelles conditions il avait
été amené à rédiger ce certificat
médical il indique très clairement dans
la procédure qu'il a fait ce certificat
médical à la demande de Robert Pichon
monsieur Pichon est allé voir son
médecin en lui disant j'aurais besoin
d'un certificat médical disant que je
suis impuissant et le médecin a rédigé
très aimablement ce certificat médical
sans faire la moindre vérification
certificat médical et l'illustration
parfaite de ce que on a rien pour dire
que Monsieur Pichon était pas impuissant
et quand bien même il le serait encore
une fois ça ne
prive pas une personne d'avoir des
attirances sexuelles malgré tout et si
Robert Pichon semble avoir tant insisté
pour obtenir ce certificat ce n'est
peut-être pas par hasard l'homme aurait
voulu se défendre de graves accusations
l'enquête nous apparaîtra nous apprendra
que Robert Pichon avait été inquiété
cette fois-ci par une plainte d'une
jeune fille d'une voisine qui alors
qu'elle avait une quinzaine d'années et
lui une cinquantaine 50 55 ans mais il y
a là aussi aurait eu des des gestes et
des propos tout à fait déplacés à
l'égard de cette jeune mineur
donc Robert Pichon on peut le dire je
veux dire c'est quelque chose qui
établit on doit jamais faire le procès
de la victime sauf qu'on c'est
nécessaire mais en tout cas on l'espèce
on peut dire très franchement que Robert
Pichon est un délinquant sexuel
et ce n'est pas tout en 1995 Robert
Pichon avait été reconnu coupable
d'attouchement sexuel sur ces deux
filles
c'est un homme pas forcément très
recommandable en bien pigeon
son ex-femme le qualifie de pervers
c'est il a il a un comportement adorable
en public devant ses voisins mais dans
le privé on a les témoignages et qui
sont pas qui sont pas très flatteurs
d'ailleurs en 2009 les enfants de Robert
Pichon se confier à des journalistes à
la télévision et l'une de ces filles
confirmait le caractère violent de son
père
[Musique]
je n'étais plus en relation avec mon
papa depuis l'âge de 16 ans
donc on voit bien que Robert Pichon il a
un caractère quand même assez déviant
alors ce que raconte nos Tellier
finalement si on évacuait et qu'on mette
de côté cette histoire d'escroquerie
c'est quelque chose qui n'a rien de
d'impossible au contraire
effectivement c'est quelqu'un qui
apparaît comme étant capable de s'en
prendre
sexuellement enfin d'agresser
sexuellement une femme
cette réputation de délinquance sexuelle
de Robert Pichon va faire naître les
plus incroyables rumeurs autour du
retraité
deux ans après les faits le corps de
Robert Pichon n'a toujours pas été
retrouvé malgré des fouilles minutieuses
de la même manière aucune trace de crime
n'a été retrouvée il n'en a pas fallu
davantage pour que les voisins de Robert
Pichon commencent à s'opposer une
question et si le vieil homme avait
choisi de disparaître volontairement
comme dans toutes les affaires de
disparition ou de meurtres en cadavre il
est évident que rapidement on se demande
parfois en souriant parfois sérieusement
et est-ce que Robert Pichon est-il
escorbapichon est mort
les gendarmes font une enquête de
voisinage et effectivement un certain
nombre de personnes pensent que Robert
Pichon est toujours vivant et qu'en fait
il aurait organisé sa propre mort tout
simplement pour échapper à des
poursuites judiciaires que tout ça n'est
qu'une mascarade et que Robert Pichon et
bel et bien vivant qui se cache de peur
de la justice
une mascarade dont les complices
auraient été mot déliés et Olivier
Benoît chargé de faire croire à sa mort
est-ce que Robert Pichon a manigance et
tout cela manipulé le couple et puis
fait en sorte de partir loin de ses eaux
où il reste encore un trouvable et de
partager les gains peut-être avec avec
le couple on s'est absolument rien du
tout certains témoins affirmeront même
avoir aperçu le vieil homme dans le sud
de la France à la terrasse d'un café bel
et bien vivant mais l'information ne
sera jamais confirmée
faute de preuves faute d'éléments mode
délier Olivier Benoît sont libérés en
novembre 2008 après un an de détention
préventive
les choses rares ici pour les suspects
d'une affaire toujours en cours les deux
jeunes gens vont multiplier les
interviews exemple en mai 2009 mode
Tellier confirme une nouvelle fois sa
version des faits elle a tué Robert
Pichon par légitime défendent
je l'ai frappé
comme une folle
j'ai passé mes nerfs sur lui
et jusqu'à temps qu'il tombe et puis
après il est tombé bouger plus
j'ai dit toute la vérité et il doute
encore donc
faut que je monte pour qu'il me croit ou
je sais pas je sais pas quoi faire
pourquoi on croit quoi franchement
j'ai tout dit dans les moindres détails
j'ai dit
30-40 fois 50 fois la même histoire
ça aurait pas été vrai je me serais
emmenée des pinceaux je me serais je
dirais pas tout le temps la même chose
quoi
juin 2011 tribunal d'Épinal après quatre
ans d'enquête le parquet requalifie
l'affaire Pichon mode Tellier et Olivier
Benoît ne seront plus jugés pour meurtre
par légitime défense mais avec
préméditation la peine encourue est
désormais beaucoup plus lourde le juge
d'instruction change son fils d'épaule
Eddy moi j'estime que j'ai suffisamment
d'égréments pour prouver que ce meurtre
était prémédité un meurtre prémédité ça
s'appelle un assassinat et là on en
cours la réclusion féminine à la
perpétude
conséquence de la requalification du
crime le couple est de nouveau incarcéré
[Applaudissements]
pour la Défense Robert Pichon a bien
agressé sexuellement mode délié certes
le couple a avoué avoir préparé
l'escroquerie à l'assurance avec le
vieil homme mais pour les deux jeunes
gens tout le reste se rêverait
de plus
pour l'accusation en revanche il s'agit
d'un crime crapuleux préparé avec soin
pour toucher l'argent de l'assurance
Robert Pichon aurait donc été victime
d'un crime avec préméditation
problème le seul élément matériel dont
dispose des enquêteurs et le pantalon de
jogging d'Olivier Benoit sur lequel a
coulé le sang de Robert Pichon seulement
il ne peut pas être considéré comme une
preuve
et voici pourquoi
[Musique]
ce que l'ADN donne au niveau matériel de
façon concrète indiscutable
incontestable c'est qu'à un moment donné
Robert Pichon a saigné à proximité même
pas d'Olivier Benoit de ce pantalon
asseyez sur ce pantalon voilà c'est ça
que ça donne stricto sensu
une seule chose est sûre c'est un procès
particulièrement compliqué qui s'annonce
on va demander une fois de plus au juré
de
remettre de l'ordre d'essayer de
remettre de l'ordre dans un dossier qui
est totalement dans des ordres est-ce
qu'on va avoir des éléments nouveaux
est-ce que la version des faits va être
maintenant est-ce que peut-être on sait
jamais on peut peut-être même espérer un
jour revoir Robert pigeon on n'en sais
rien c'est le charme de cette affaire
sinon c'est que on est en perpétuel
spéculation alors qu'il y a des années
d'enquêtes c'est pas fréquent des
affaires on n'a pas de cadavre pas de
pas de pas d'armes pas de mobile pas de
preuve et et
où ce sont les auteurs présumés qui
viennent se dénoncer et s'il ne s'était
pas dénoncé
il n'aurait probablement pas été
inquiété et ce pourquoi il se dénonce
c'est à peine convaincant
tout ça et
assez unique le procès en assise de mot
délier d'Olivier Benoît devrait se tenir
dans les mois qui viennent en attendant
d'être jugé ils sont toujours en
détention provisoire
quant à Robert Pichon il reste
mystérieusement introuvable
[Musique]